the United States added 156,000 new jobs
in December of 2016 this top two million
jobs created by the Obama administration
during 2016 it also was month number 75
of consecutive job growth in the US that
is six and a quarter consecutive years
of job growth the unemployment rate
ticking up slightly from four point six
percent to four-point-seven percent this
is very close to what we consider full
employment and on that note I want to
dig into that a little bit sometimes
people wonder well why is
four-point-seven percent full employment
don't we want zero if one out of 20
people are considered formally
unemployed isn't that bad imagine if the
unemployment rate were zero even if it
were just the u3 nevermind the u6 and if
you don't know what the difference is
between the two all I'll get to that in
a second how do businesses expand and
how do you have net job growth when
there's no unemployed people when there
aren't unemployed people all hiring
depends on people leaving one job to go
to another that's not job growth that's
job switching and there's also no labor
pool to draw from and very interestingly
the unemployment rate for college
graduates is two-point-five percent it
really doesn't get more full employment
than that and it's interesting to ask
people what they think the college
graduate unemployment rate is they think
it's very very high when you say well
listen the the total unemployment rate
is under five percent uh people often
don't realize that among college
graduates the unemployment rate is
effectively non-existent and III know
people will say well some of those
people aren't in good jobs yeah I
understand that and that's a problem and
we want to address job quality one other
thing Pat is and I know you want to jump
in here wages average hourly earnings up
two-point-nine percent that's the
fastest growth rate dating all the way
back to June of 2009 well just in terms
of the college unemployment rate I think
the way that question is worded makes
people think of people who are just out
of college and we we see so much about
students just getting out they have so
much debt and the guy and find a job I
think it's more about terminology there
yet that could there could be confusion
there
so at this point I have to do some
normal explanations to preempt
conspiracy theories we often hear from
the right one of those conspiracy
theories is David these numbers are
meaningless because when you stopped
looking for work you're no longer
considered unemployed that is true with
the u3 rate which is the way it's been
measured for decades when you stopped
looking for work either because you're
discouraged worker or because you're
retiring or choosing to be a
stay-at-home parent you no longer a part
of the u3 that's nothing new that's
nothing that's new under the Obama
administration if you look at the u6
that includes discouraged workers people
working part-time who want to be full
time that has dropped in parallel with
the u3 again this is nothing new there's
no Obama era conspiracy theory there and
by the way the u6 is no more real as an
unemployment rate in the u3 they just
measure different things you can't say
look at the u6 under Obama but i was
happy using the u3 under george w bush
last thing you will hear the conspiracy
theory there's a hundred billion people
unemployed or 90 million or whatever
because if you look at the labor force
participation rate it is so so low folks
that includes retired people and we have
baby boomer retirement growing and
growing the labor force conspiracy
theories are considering college
students who are just full time students
as part of the unemployment problem if
you're a high school junior or senior
who's just going to high school and not
working you're part of that one of those
of people who is part of the labor force
it includes people who are stay-at-home
parents by choice it includes people
working part-time by choice it is such a
bogus conspiracy theory but yet every
time it you see it in the YouTube
comments yeah I'm pretty much all these
indicators it looks like the economy is
doing quite well and has been during the
duration of most of rock obama's
presidency yeah so with all the facts on
figure in figures on our side it's
interesting to see people like Newt
Gingrich say well the American public
doesn't feel like the economy's doing so
well right all of a sudden the party
that says we care about facts not
feelings cares about feelings what we're
going to do on january twentieth we will
put up for you the bush numbers the
obama numbers and we will start the
stopwatch on Donald Trump are going to
look at jobs
dated we're going to look at the
unemployment rate wages stock market
labor force participation to the extent
that the right wing claims to care about
it might be something they only care
about when it's a Democrat in the White
House we'll look at GDP growth and the
import-export ratio and we'll measure
who does what and what happens bottom
line in total the economy has added over
11 million jobs during President Obama's
presidency Trump claims to be the guy
for jobs right let's see how he does
starting in just about 11 days Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / tdps I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick 5
pairs that i liked put them on in the
comfort of my own home pick the one I
like the most and then Warby Parker put
my prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing